- Hi guys,
my name is Heinrich from Firm Learning.
Welcome back,
and thank you for watching.
This video is another video in my series,
on how to improve your management
business presentations,
to adopt a style that is followed
by top management consulting firms
like BCG, Bain or McKinsey.
This video focuses on slide blueprints.
Very frequently you are in a situation
where in a short amount of time,
you need to produce a significant number
of PowerPoint pages of
slides for a presentation.
In these situations, what is just crucial
is that you do not need to start
for every single page to ask yourself
well, how do I put the
information on paper?
What structure do I use?
How exact do I present it?
If you do that you will
take hours and hours
to even create basic
PowerPoint presentations.
What's crucial and what
people in consulting do
is they use slide blueprints.
There are certain structures
that they can adopt,
and just reuse,
and where they know is that if I present
the information this specific way,
then it will be at least good enough,
everybody will clearly understand
what I'm going to say,
maybe it's not the most
fancy, most beautiful page,
but it's going to meet
professional standards
and I can bring my information across.
And as you maybe know,
frequently in consulting,
you're in a situation
where, literally overnight,
you need to create presentations
of 10, 20, 30 pages,
and here it's just crucial
that you are in a position
to be able to produce this content quickly
and to a high level of quality
and without slide blueprints in this way,
this is just impossible.
As the other videos on creating
PowerPoint presentations,
This video is an excerpt on my course.
You can find a link to
the video description,
if you would like to check it out.
And please have a look at the reviews
of the other students who already took it,
if you ask yourself,
is this actually the right thing for you.
But now without further ado,
let's dive into it.
Let's learn about slide blueprints,
I trust that this is
really going to be helpful
in improving your production
flow in the future.
So before we jump
into some very specific slide blueprints,
let me just talk about
some general principles.
And first I'd like to talk
about things to avoid,
because then you know
that these are things
that you would definitely
not use on your pages.
And then also some key
principles to follow,
these are things that
you should look after,
because they will help your
slide production process.
So first some things to avoid.
So, and maybe also just to start,
I mean, these are just
kind of rule of thumbs.
So it might be that in some cases,
it does make sense and it
is okay to do these things.
Just from my experience
that most in of the cases,
you do not want to do this, okay.
So the first point to avoid
are extensive color fields,
especially behind text.
And a color field would
be something like this,
so kind of a box that
is filled with a color,
and what some people like to do
is they like to take these kind of boxes,
and put them below the text.
So imagine this kind of list of bullets
would have such a blue box behind them.
And some people do that a lot,
and they feel like this
somehow looks good or whatever.
And I mean, I don't wanna argue with you,
whether it looks good or not
because I guess this is subjective.
But I think there's at
least two strong reasons
why you shouldn't do that.
So first,
if kind of you have it on a beamer right,
the presentation,
or maybe the beamer isn't
so good or whatever.
So the kind of project
off the presentation,
it just might not be a really
good read of it, right.
So if you have kind of a color
below or behind your text,
the contrast isn't really good.
So just kind of makes it more difficult
for the reader to read.
And the second reason is and
where this kind of becomes
even more relevant, if you print it out.
And what you will see very often is that
these presentations are being printed out
in black and white.
Many corporates have even policies,
to whenever possible,
only print out things
in black and white without color.
because it saves cost of course.
And even though maybe on your computer,
if you have it with a color,
in the textbox behind it,
maybe then it looks good,
it looks reasonable.
It looks very readable.
But it's often very hard to kind of know
how it will look like if you print it out
on a black and white kind of color scheme,
especially maybe if the
printer isn't really good.
And then you would easily
find yourself in a situation
where the text on the bullets
is not really very
readable anymore, right?
So avoid extensive color fields.
This is my kind of recommendation
from my experience having done this
for many, many years, avoid them,
they add no value to your presentation.
And there are lots of risks
in terms of readability
if you do that.
And let me just kind of to contrast it
to what I did here, of
course you could argue,
well then you know what did you do
here on the left, right,
because this is also a color field.
And while I do like to
use color fields I get
for kind of titles, right?
Or if you would like
to highlight something,
and you could say this is kind of a title.
And this is why this is highlighted.
And this is kind of the
general texts field.
And so would say this is kind
of a bit of a gray area thing,
because it's usually only
little text that you have here
or just kind of really adds meaning,
because this highlight
really means that kind
of on a hierarchy level,
this stands above the other text field,
I think you can justify it this way,
then probably you could easily also have,
done this without this text field,
just having bolded this or whatever.
So just think about if
it's really required
in any given instance that you wanna do,
and if in doubt, leave it out.
Don't do it and you
will usually be better.
Another general example that
I can just really urge you
not to do is the usage of
shadows and 3D elements,
and probably especially 3D elements.
I mean, some light shadows
can sometimes be okay.
But this is also the idea
that some people just think
that the presentation,
to make it good,
you just need to make it look fancy.
And what does it mean
to make it look fancy?
Well, you want to add as
much effects and so on,
that are somehow available in PowerPoint
to all the different objects as possible.
And the problem is that, usually,
this doesn't really make it look fancy,
it just looks stupid, right?
I mean, most of the cases,
it looks better if you don't apply it
than if you do apply it.
And indeed, in a professional context,
it just kind of considered bad style,
just kind of consider
probably even unprofessional
to create a presentation
which is full of shadows
and full of 3D elements.
And probably the reason why
this is considered this way
is because it kind of gives the impression
that you were much more
concerned about adding
some kind of weird graphic
effects to a presentation
than about focusing on the content
and the things that really matter.
And so I mean, in general,
you probably I mean,
you might sometimes see a shadow,
but you almost never will see one of these
kind of strange PowerPoint 3D elements,
or whatever your presentation program
is able to do on the page.
So just in general avoid it
and you will be fine off.
And in a very similar direction goes
the thing of smart arts.
So this is a PowerPoint
specific functionality,
where PowerPoint allows you to create
some kind of frameworks,
some kind of process bars
and all kinds of different
variations of that on the page.
And it's supposed to help
you to kind of create
these kind of frameworks
on your page more easily
than you would have to,
then know you would be able
to create them by yourself, if you just
kind of put it together yourself,
from all the individual
elements they consist of.
But just from my experiences again,
is something that isn't really used
in a professional context.
And the reason why is I mean,
if you use these kind of things,
you will notice just that
it's just extremely difficult
to really make them look nice,
and clean and professional.
And usually the font sizes
are all over the place,
they will be like
multiple font sizes in it,
the proportions of the text
to the elements doesn't really look good.
I mean, it just almost impossible
to kind of customize it and
make it look good, right?
And so basically what
everybody's doing is, I mean,
the visual itself are
of course okay, right,
it's totally fine to have
some kind of process bar logic
or whatever on your page.
But usually what you would do
is you would just create it yourself.
You wouldn't use these pre-made templates.
So basically you would go to
the icon section of PowerPoint,
and then you would just
kind of drag and drop
the individual elements that you need,
and then it would just create
whatever you need yourself.
And then you have full flexibility
in editing it in a properly.
Another point is unnecessary
background images.
So some people just like to kind of put
some random images somewhere on the page
because they think it looks cool
and fancy and whatever.
I mean, this is the same
and it goes back to all the
things that I just taught you.
I mean, don't do it, right.
Usually it doesn't add value.
Of course, if you have an
image that does add value,
that is relevant to the presentation,
then of course add it,
but usually it just supposed
to be some kind of decoration,
and then it's just distracting
from the things that you really wanna say,
and that really are relevant.
So don't do this, right,
it just doesn't make sense.
Another point is multiple
font sizes on one page.
And what just as a general rule,
you want to avoid
is to having multiple font
sizes on the same page,
with the exception being
the action title, right?
So the action title, it's
fine if it's a bit larger,
but usually you never wanna have
different font sizes on one page,
because it really looks bad.
I mean, the look and feel of
your slides is much better,
excuse me,
the look and feel of your
slides is much better
if all the font sizes look the same.
And if you look kind of the presentation
that I prepared here
throughout this course,
I just hope that I never use
multiple font sizes on one page.
So just really try to avoid it.
And most consulting firms is
actually a really hard rule.
So you just don't do it.
It's often tempting because sometimes,
you just want to fit this in on the page,
and there just isn't the space,
and if you kind of just put this one box
in a smaller font size,
and everything would fit in nicely.
And of course, it's a trade off,
and sometimes it saves you time.
So if you wanna do this, then fine,
I'm not going to stop you.
But in general,
if you just really want to make sure
that your presentation looks nice,
and clean and professional, don't do it.
So what are the things that you should do?
What are the principles
that you should follow?
And here are two principles
that I would like to kind
of to quickly present to you
and the first is every page has a table,
and every page speaks for itself.
And on the first one,
I do not want to go into
too much detail right now,
because this is what we
were gonna focus on a detail
in the next I think two or so lectures.
And the concept, but just to
quickly introduce you to it
is that just in order
to make a good table,
just always think about sorry,
in order to make a good page,
just always think about the
page as being a table, right.
And for instance, on this example,
you could think of this page
as being a table with two columns.
This is the first column.
And this is the second column.
So this is some kind of a title column,
where you kind of introduce
and name the things that
you wanna talk about.
And this is kind of a detail column
where you give specifics and details
of the things that you're
talking about here.
oops sorry.
And so but let me just leave you at this
because we will go into detail
kind of on the next couple
of lectures on this.
And so let me just spend some
words on the second principle,
every page speaks for itself.
And maybe you remember the section
or the lecture that we had on diagrams,
and I think there was one extra called,
every chart speaks for itself.
And the concept here is the very same.
And just to kind of give you an anecdote,
when I was a young
consultant, I had a partner,
and he tried to explain
to me exactly this, right,
every page speaks for itself.
And what he told me is kind
of the following instance,
he told me, you know,
Heinrich, imagine you are
working in a client room.
And for whatever reason,
you were having a presentation there,
and then you left one of the pages
of the presentation in
the room, accidentally.
Of course, this is something
that should never happen,
due to a whole lot of reasons.
Probably the most important
one is confidentiality.
But let's just imagine
that you left one page
in the client room.
And now what you want to achieve,
what you want to aspire to,
whenever you create a presentation,
that basically a random person
could grab this one page that you left,
could look at it, could
understand what it means
without anybody being there,
and would say, yeah okay,
this is solid piece of rock.
This is a good page, right?
And so what it means
is probably two things.
First, that you always make sure
that even though of course content
is the most important thing,
the things that you actually write on it,
you always make sure that
a certain minimum quality
of design is met, right.
So I mean, your pages always
need to look well aligned,
need to look decent, and so on.
But then regarding the content,
that you make sure that
it is self-contained,
in the way that everybody can understand
the most important messages of the slide,
just by reading it themself,
without anybody needing
to explain it to him.
So every page speaks for
itself is an important,
very important concept,
within kind of management presentations,
and top management kind of areas.
You know, when you talk with CEOs,
he wants to be able to
understand what you wanna say
himself without you needing to be there.
So follow these two principles.
And you slide creation process
will be much more straightforward
and the next kind of topic now
that I really wanna
detail as I just told you
is every page has a table.
And this is now the blueprint
aspect of this, right?
I mean, if you understand this,
you have a good blueprint
of all the pages.
So let's dive into this right now.
In this lecture,
I'd like to build on
what we just discussed
in the last lecture,
namely, on the principle,
every page as a table.
And the reason I'm saying
this is the following,
what you need is a design blueprint,
that you can quickly
pull out of your pocket,
whenever you want to create
big presentation document
without needing to think every time
kind of for lots of time,
how should the page look like,
how should the slide look
like, that I wanna create.
And this basic blueprint
means that you should always
think of every single page
that you create as a table.
And what I would like to show you now
on the next kind of slides that
I would go through with you,
are a couple of examples
of how pages look like,
and you would always see
this part on this in the end,
every page is just a table, right?
So you always have just ask yourself,
what is the information that I have?
And how can I arrange it in a way
that it fits nicely into a table.
So let's start with a simple text table.
This is a very simple example
that we see right here.
And I hope that you can recognize
this table form that you see here.
Basically, this thing has two columns,
measures and rationale.
And then there are a couple of rows,
and you see every row and
this kind of example here
represents an area location here,
some kind of a customer segment and so on.
Let's not focused too much on the contents
of what's shown here,
but just rather than on the structure.
And this is something that
you will see quite frequently,
of some kind of a title column like that.
And then you have some details provided
by the title or on the title
that was introduced here.
Of course, this page is quite wordy,
as you would say, right.
So it has lots of text,
probably it's a bit too wordy
to put it in your main deck.
This could be more something
like you would have in your backup.
But this is kind of just a basic example
how you can arrange your
text in the table format.
Now let's look at something similar,
maybe a bit more advanced,
maybe a bit more complex.
And probably on first sight,
you would say, yes,
this is a good looking,
nice slide, right.
But in the end,
this just follows a table format as well.
And as you can see,
you have these different columns here.
And then there is a bit
of space here on the right
with this thing that kind of pops out,
you would call this a callout, right,
so you add details to specific elements.
In this kind of context, it
is on the industry opportunity
expressing courier services,
and on the industry
opportunity of coal mining.
And you make this callout here
where you add this additional text.
But what you can see is
that in terms of design,
in the end, this is also
some kind of a table column,
just doesn't have a title,
but it fits nicely to the
right as a table column.
And again, this is also typically designed
where you have kind of
certain kinds of elements
that you wanna range,
you order them by one criterium.
And here it's a data point
that you use to all of them,
namely the revenue pool,
which is, a data point that we put here,
it could be anything else.
And then you provide
some additional details
and their qualitative assessment.
But again, this is now
rather complex information
that you have on these different elements,
but it is presented in a table format.
Just one more example.
This again, is kind of
a page that summarizes
certain data points on
kind of different elements
in this case, we have
infrastructure data management,
analytics platforms and
services and support.
So that these could be seen
as values, the process points
or maybe even industries
that you wanna look at.
And again, here we have some data points,
the CAGR component and your growth rate,
and then a qualitative
assessment of some drivers,
and this is very typical kind
of collection of information
that you would like to give
this top management style presentation.
And once again, you can transform it
or kind of presented in the way
that it is shown as a table.
And the reason I'm putting so
much emphasis on this is that,
in the end, when you create presentations,
and you need to create lots of pages
in a short amount of time,
what it's important for you to have
is kind of a basic blueprint
in your head, right?
How should the pages
that are made look like,
because then you don't need to focus
so much on the design anymore,
because you already know
how you will arrange
the information, namely
in the form of a table.
And then you can kind of the
limited time that you have,
spent much more effectively
by just kind of focusing
on the content, and then
the design just follows
this table format that you can just use
as a blueprint for all your pages.
Building on that I would like
to show you a slightly more
kind of complicated, a
bit more advanced page
that is still created following
the exact same principle.
So this is a page and just to guide you
through the logic, right,
this is a page showing
the industry market volume
of different industries and then
kind of identify opportunities
that this company isn't currently serving.
So it looks at the total
industry, these 922 million,
it looks at what part
of it is already served
by the company we're looking at.
It looks at kind of a
segment of the industry,
which we cannot serve at the moment
because we lacked
relevant product offering.
And then we identify an opportunity
that we currently do not serve,
but actually have the relevant offering.
So this is probably a
bit more advanced logic.
And then what you see here,
as well as that there's
something like a double
click on this field, right.
So this nicely fits into
the double click principle
that we talked about earlier.
So what is happening here is we basically
make a virtual double click
on this potential opportunities row.
And then it expands here on the right,
that we detail the five industries
that we see as potential
opportunities here.
And then provide bit more
information about what we think,
excuse me,
what we think are the next steps here
that we need to look into.
But coming back to the principle,
every page has a table, in
this rather complex design,
you still see that it's
basically just a page
which is exactly two columns,
first industry analysis,
and then this detailed column.
And then we have these
individual rows here,
which represent parts of the industry
that we segment in this way.
And now by looking at this bubble,
which says by the legend here
on the top number of industries,
so this represents the number
of different industries
that we see into these categories.
And I mean, this again,
can be seen this another column
of the table as well, right?
It doesn't have a header in the sense here
that something's stated here.
But the way it is put here is the column.
And let's put beside of course,
or within the role that represents
the respective category,
where we see this number
of industries to fit.
So again, the principle,
every purchaser table,
and you can see that
you can use this kind
of framework to expand
on one of the row elements that you have,
if you wanna provide some details.
And this is often helpful if
you want to kind of provide
details on the most important role.
And this probably would be a good example
because the role of the
potential opportunities is indeed
the most important one of this page,
it is the row
that you wouldn't really
want to provide the dates on.
But you can also use it if you
kind of in a bit more arbitrary
or selective way you have a
list of different elements
that you talk about.
And then maybe you just
wanna go into detail,
into one of these elements.
Maybe also because you have the most
interesting things to show
for this specific element.
Then in a bit arbitrary way,
you can make a callout just like that
and double click just like that,
where you selectively provide
details on the specific
element of your table.
And kind of making this even more general,
you can use a blueprint just
as depicted on this page,
as just the general
blueprint that is applicable
whenever you have any
kind of data analysis,
that you would like to visualize.
And kind of this very
simple basic blueprint
that you can use for many
different types of pages
goes like this,
that in the middle of the page,
you put a chart,
kind of highlighting the
analysis that you have made.
So some chart visualizing the data
that you would like to
present to your audience,
and then on the right to make
a column with implications.
So here with a few bullets you write,
what you actually learn from the analysis
that you did, right,
or what are the key takeaways,
what are the implications,
from the analysis that you prepared.
And then and this is maybe
a bit more kind of arbitrary
or you have to kind of ask yourself
whether it is really be necessary.
But what then you can also
do is typically to the left,
you would insert a new
column with the methodology.
So what are kind of the things,
the steps that you undertook
in order to come up with exactly
this data analysis that you created.
And why would you do it
from from left to right,
so first methodology, then the chart,
and then the applications
where because the usual way
somebody reads a page is
indeed from left to right.
And if you directly start with
the implications on the left,
probably it would surprise many people
because it's not really clear
how you derive these implications.
But if somebody reads from left to right,
and he first sees the
chart, so the analysis,
and you also understood
how you came up with it,
then it's kind of more logical
and just follows the natural
kind of way of thought,
the natural kind of argumentation chain,
to then come up with implications
and then talking about what other things
that you actually learning.
And putting this to practice
with a page example.
This is a page that shows exactly that.
So here you have some kind of
data analysis in this case,
depicting my market dynamics by region
with kind of different
data points that are shown.
And then on the right,
you are inserting a new
column with a key insights,
the key implications with the things
to really take away from state analysis.
And in this case,
there is no column inserted
to the left with the methodology.
And I mean, if the methodology
would be less straightforward,
you could definitely
include such a column here.
It's always a case by case decision
whether you think it's necessary.
But notice here how this
blueprint was applied.
And indeed,
you can apply this to lots
and lots of different cases.
And please notice again,
how the every page is a card, sorry,
every page is a table principle
was applied here, right?
You have this big first column
kind of detailing the data analysis
and then you have the
column here on the right,
detailing the implications.
And then if you look into the specifics
of kind of how the chart is presented,
you can see that this is kind
of a table as well, right,
you have sorry,
you have your the first row
show the operating margin.
This is kind of the excess
label for the y-axis.
And then on the same height
neatly aligned to it,
the legend.
And then below you have another column.
So yet another role with a CAGR
so the label of the x-axis.
And then below that you have
a role for the footnotes.
So this is again, the
much more complex page,
following this layout blueprint,
which I really would encourage you to use,
if you create these kind of pages.
Thanks again for watching.
If you got some value out of the video,
please press the like button
and subscribe to the channel here below.
If you would like to keep up to date
with future content for
my channel Firm Learning,
and covering topics on
business and management.
And I want to ma...